hablamos de salud tendría hecho américa
de france 24 ya está conmigo en el
estudio marina sardina marina bienvenida
bueno mañana vamos a china donde hay una
alerta a un nuevo virus que se contagia
a los humanos deberíamos preocuparnos
marina y de qué se trata exactamente
este virus bueno raúl buenos días
nosotros no vamos a generar la alarma
pero si efectivamente se ha publicado un
nuevo estudio en la revista new england
journal of medicine' que publicó como
decimos un steve un estudio que alertaba
de la detención de al menos 35 personas
contagiadas con un nuevo tipo de gen y
para virus en las provincias chinas de
general y shandong que es un gen y que
para virus te preguntarás raúl este
género pertenece a la familia
paramixovirus es alarmante porque estos
patógenos representan una alta
mortalidad en humanos por esto está
clasificado como virus de nivel 4 de
bioseguridad con tasas de mortalidad
entre el 40 y el 75 por ciento según la
o ms esto es mucho más alto raúl y el
cob y 19 algunos son patógenos
zoonóticos o sea que se transmiten de
animales a personas este nuevo gen y
para virus ha sido denominado lang jenny
para virus hasta ahora el virus no ha
tenido unas consecuencias fatales ni
graves por lo que los doctores que
participaron en este estudio llaman a la
calma en las personas contagiadas los
científicos hallaron un amplio abanico
de síntomas raúl que van desde la fiebre
en el 100% de los casos cansancio
pérdida de apetito una pérdida también o
vómitos y estos fueron los principales
síntomas de este nuevo virus detectado
ahora le pregunto cómo se transmite a
nosotros los humanos y cuál es el
alcance su gravedad marina todavía hay
muchas incógnitas como decimos pero el
principal sospechoso son las musarañas y
la posibilidad de que sea un virus
zoonótico los científicos analizaron 25
especies de pequeños animales salvajes y
el adn de la pnc ya virus fue detectado
predominantemente en las musarañas en un
27% lo que esto sugiere que las
musarañas podrían ser un reservorio
natural de este virus en lo cualquier
caso todavía no está claro si el virus
se puede transmitir entre personas y los
investigadores señalaron que la muestra
es muy pequeña para determinar el tipo
de transmisión no la vía de transmisión
los científicos reiteran que factores
como el cambio climático raúl que lo
veníamos hablando también ayer o la
destrucción de la naturaleza pues
favorece estos patógenos y su conexión
con los animales entre animales y los
humanos así es marina y seguimos
hablando de la viruela del mono no
olvidamos también esta enfermedad porque
la administración de alimentos y
medicamentos de eeuu utilizó la vacuna
niños para su uso emergencia mediante
inyección intradérmica en personas de 18
años de más de 18 años que se consideran
de alto riesgo no marina así así es que
eeuu sigue siendo el país con mayor
número de contagios de viruela del mono
con más de 9.500 casos que como
recordemos en todo el mundo hay casi
32.000 positivos ante este crecimiento
que vive la nación americana como decía
se aprueba una nueva estrategia con el
fin de dosificar las dosis disponibles
de la vacuna ya existente para tratar la
enfermedad que es la línea eeuu cuenta
con unas 1,1 millones de dosis
disponibles de las que ya se han
administrado más de 600.000 a personas
de alto riesgo pero en un intento de
frenar este brote
emitió una autorización de uso de
emergencia que permite al profesional
sanitario un régimen de dosificación
alternativo para aumentar así también el
número de viales
disponibles multiplicándolo por hasta
cinco veces esto fue lo que dijo la
directora del centro de control
prevención de enfermedades
esta estrategia cambiaría el método de
administración de la vacuna guineos de
subcutáneo a intra de mikko para
permitir a los proveedores de vacunas
utilizar un vial existente de una dosis
de la vacuna para administrar un total
de hasta cinco dosis separadas causas
según la cede a la administración
intradérmica produjo una respuesta
inmune similar a la administración
subcutánea raúl este método consiste en
administrar el suero de la capa superior
de la piel utilizando una aguja más fina
y menos cantidad de vacuna pero que como
decíamos tiene la misma efectividad y es
igualmente necesario dos dosis de esta
vacuna inoculadas en un intervalo de
cuatro semanas por su parte la compañía
danesa y dueña de esta vacuna bavarian
nordic detrás de esta única vacuna que
como decimos se está repartiendo en todo
el mundo envió una carta mostrando sus
reticencias y señalando que habría sido
prudente realizar más estudios antes de
revisar esta estrategia nacional como ha
hecho eeuu algunos funcionarios creen
raúl que esto también es que esta
compañía está un poco preocupada por sus
ganancias económicas no ya que podría
ser eeuu un ejemplo para otras naciones
claro pues marina muchísimas gracias
como siempre por toda la información en
torno a salud y pasamos entonces a
saludar a nuestro segundo invitado el
día